let's go brushfire welcome back to Dead
Rising 2 everybody dance now everybody
dance dance dance dance dance
say hi to silly bear say hi oh my god
that is a lot of Sammy's going oh no
they can't not bad take all my money I
don't need it
a [ __ ] I don't need it take this but
watch what was in that bottle their
heads are exploding it must be the new
Justin Bieber single oh my god is super
effective they're all exploding get more
of those single samples
this one is Miley Cyrus new single take
it Oh cover your ears
don't listen to it yeah where is Eddie
there you are
I'm sorry I missed you taste him what is
black people saying those one song
shoddy I'm [ __ ] fabulous now shut up
ah I blew it up just so you wouldn't do
that your page I shot gimme hugs gimme
hugs kill him kill him Eddie
stupid whoa whoa that is actually pretty
badass that's like a pirate sword I'm
great ed shut up funeral car
how fitting oh we can't take too much
damage
oh good thing I'm not taking any damage
that's either a zombie or a man with
swag either way doesn't matter what
those boots there we go that's what I'm
talking about
it is put some made for walking but that
is what they do so may these boots are
gonna walk a bucket hahahahahahah job
nailed a goddamn it Oh goddamnit
Sun up up that I out can still do it
oh don't climb it if it's on fire
oh well that's good that that was their
electric staff um okay whoa let me out
ow ow ow why what's wrong with this car
Oh Oh No my new skirt it'll ruin you
won't pay for this [ __ ] party slapper
that's my car
this is my car oh my god it's this whoa
oh my god
now this is my car I'll clean up all
your dirty [ __ ] I'll clean up your
hose with my hose
oh my god they become balloons that is
adorable
what the actual [ __ ] is that what they
I'm gonna have nightmares for years what
is that oh I better get sucked in oh
this is the best thing that ever
happened to me I'm saying is that all
right what is this Bellanca mask all
right and watch me poop electric
diarrhea I like you as a friend and all
but I don't see that you're that way
come on man you should know ooh
Toy Story there better be something good
in here I bet you there is oh yeah I got
the whole outfit all right that's right
yes we are looking fab we are looking
absolutely fantastic
hahaha best zombie fighting outfit ever
whoo hey do you ever want to be this
first Sambi in space there you go
Hey oh they just came back fly on the
wings of love flesh and beef laughs oh
my god I got brofist way everyone gets a
profit I'm like Oprah purified you get a
brofist you get a profit you get a
breakfast everyone gasps bro phase I
gotta clear this jump I we can do it yes
focus yes yes nailed it
best jump in my entire life look at that
come on come on oh god oh god oh god oh
god uh I'm gonna act as sit oh my god
what a face this is so childish take it
oh God hahahahahahahaha worth worth it
worth it take it up Oh Mike oh my god
I'll catch oh my god I love you you're
my new best friend oh my god this is
just what I need
don't touch me I'm building [ __ ] now my
BOB I need it for detonating on oh god
here will be a great spot I would think
just how do i this can't be it
what the [ __ ] this is hockey here we go
here we go here we go here we go hey oh
god it's gonna blow it's gonna blow yeah
that's kinda bruh all right I have an
appointment with the dentist
well Buddha PI survived the explosion
leave a like and favorite and find out
in the next episode say arson Birds